eric jared congratulations your weapons
were strong enough to propel you into
this final round of competition which
means you're both one step closer to the
title of forged and fire champion in
that check for ten thousand dollars
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to create an iconic blade from
history
the hungamanga
[Music]
the term hungamunga refers to a variety
of central african throwing knives all
of which feature a series of
double-edged iron blades attached to a
rawhide handle the hungamunga was not
only formidable in hand-to-hand combat
but could be thrown from a distance with
some reports claiming it had a throwing
range of up to 250 feet as armor was not
used often in central africa this type
of throwing iron was particularly
devastating hungamanga was often very
valuable and could be traded for goods
the hungamunga was also wielded by buffy
summers in the cult series buffy the
vampire slayer
first thing i thought was
[Laughter]
i was not expecting that
your weapon must fall within the
following parameters it must have a
sharpened head crescent blade a spear
and a spike you must also include a
handle arm to sharpen spike above the
handle
it must be an effective working version
of that deadly weapon however we want
you to make something that's unique that
could only come from your forge
i'm looking forward to decking this
hunga manga out putting my own signature
style and the details decorative work
i'm trying to think of how complicated
this thing will be to build it's
complicated forging
you will have five days at your home
forge to complete this challenge at the
end of those five days you will return
and present your finished weapons to our
panel of expert judges
only after they've subjected your
weapons to a series of brutal tests
will they declare one of you the force
and fire champion who walks away with
that check for 10 grand
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
[Music]
first day really happy to be back in my
shop i have never made anything even
remotely like this before
this is like a cross between a sword
boomerang
chakram
battle axe
i gotta plan this out i'm gonna start
with this blade then pull this off from
the side and then start working the
spike in this is a wild build
[Music]
so i'm gonna have to heat this all up
i'm gonna have to drive this down
that's almost a chess game i've got to
think like five moves ahead on this
thing because if i screw up once it
could completely ruin the piece of steel
i got and i got to start over
this chunk here hopefully turned into my
sickle blade here
maybe if i heat this area here swinging
this out of the way here
i'm gonna push that up into there then i
can push this around
that's
beer point's gonna be
[Music]
it's day three i'm a little sore but i
got the blade profile forged out and i
feel great about my blade design
bam
i still think it looks like something
from whoville now it's time for the heat
treat
everything leading up to this point is
just critical
all right here we go
beautiful
i was totally giddy when i got it out of
the quench and i just want to give it a
test throw
this thing is definitely a lethal weapon
just not a prop
it's definitely something you don't want
thrown at you it will stick
plan for today is finish up the pommel
carving the sunbeam and then uh wrap the
handle
this was a really difficult piece to
forge and to create
maybe i should have some some worries
going into the final round but i really
don't
i did the best i can do i'm super
confident in what i made and just see
how it pans out
i think this thing's gonna just perform
spectacularly
my competitor he better really bring his
a-game because i'm feeling good
bladesmiths to see how sharp your blades
are i will take your weapon and i will
test the crescent-shaped blade and the
spear
if your blade is sharp it should last
away cleanly through this stretched
jared you're up first are you ready i am
let's do this
well jared your handle wrap feels good
to the hand the blade of your crescent
and your spear right there is sharp
enough to lacerate cleanly through the
stretch out leather it will cut good job
sir thank you
eric you're up ready yes sir
okay eric
nice grip
your crescent edge over here at the
initial start not so sharp but once you
got it going it lacerated your spear
edge same thing it started off here but
once it got going it lacerated not all
edges are as sharp as the other but it
is sharp enough to cut my concern was
this design that you have over here for
this you know being that it's a weapon
that you move around
having that pointed at me is never a
good idea right
otherwise though this blade
will cut
good job
thanks that first slice
skipped across and it got to a port
where it was sharper blade's not
performing well i'm quite disappointed
bladesmiths this is a kill test the
hunger manga was a weapon with multiple
configurations of blades on top of a
blade to see how lethal your weapon is
according to its design i will take your
weapon and i will deliver multiple
strikes on this ballistics dummy let's
see how lethal your blade is jared
you're up first you ready definitely
[Music]
[Music]
he looks like he's bleeding
well jared every facet and design of
your blade
will definitely do damage your crescent
edge nicely lacerated through
the tip on that hooked and gutted
whatever was in there your small blade i
had to angle a little bit because
there's not much space over there but as
you can see if you work it according to
its design you can jab right into it and
of course your spear tip crushed through
the bones and into the heart this sir
will kill
great job thank you eric you're up next
yes sir let's do this
[Music]
get that laceration there
okay eric your spike right there it's in
a good position because i can easily
go in there without worrying about this
getting in the way so we come to the
spear tip that went through all the way
broke bone and into the heart your
weapon will kill good job sir thank you
next up is the strength test for that
i'll pass you on to dave
gentlemen we've seen that the hunger
manga can be used as a close-quartered
weapon but it was specifically designed
to be thrown so to test the strength of
your weapon i'm going to throw it three
times into our wooden target here if
your heat treat is sound the structural
integrity of your weapon should hold up
to the impact if not we could have a
catastrophic failure
jared you're up first ready all right
safeties
nice
damn split
that's
cool nice
no catastrophic failures i'm happy it
didn't break
yeah
i put myself in the arm yeah it's the
scratch
really happy with my design final throw
sticks in beautifully well as you can
see this is a dangerous weapon all the
way around it feels really good in the
hand all that forward weight makes it
rotate beautifully your edge is still a
razor blade
and once this thing's traveling i don't
want to be on the other side of him your
cord wrap made it really nice to throw
well executed thank you eric
your turn you ready
let's do it
all right
there you go
nice
well eric this feels pretty good in the
hand
i like all this detail you did down in
here i mean it doesn't affect the throw
it doesn't affect the strength but still
it's there
dug in nicely
when it hit up here it kind of bounced
out it it scored up the wood it would
have taken a man out the other two
throws dug in nicely looks to me like
your edge is held up fine yeah it's
still all right and tight
nice and done eric thank you
eric jared you've both done fantastic
work on your hung among us however in
this arena of competition there can only
be one forged and fire champion
[Music]
jared congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion
eric your hungamunga did not make the
cut dave we'll explain eric the addition
of that spike on the back was a question
mark but at the end it came down to the
overall finish in construction and the
way it did not performed in the
sharpness test that's why we got to let
you go eric please surrender your hunger
manga
the judge's feedback i agree completely
i have no regrets whatsoever i came here
to prove that i could do it that i could
overcome a task that was seemingly
impossible
i may not be the fortune fire champion
but i can only go up from here
jared congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars how do you feel
i don't know what to say really
it's kind of a shock right now
that's
straight up the prettiest and most
terrifying thing we've ever had on the
show i mean the combination of the two i
want it that's how i feel about it and i
don't feel like that about a lot of
knots but that's a cool piece
thank you
i won still kind of settling in
10 grand is going into the shop there'll
probably be a little trip involved for
my fiance and myself boy having the
title of forge and fire champion it's
gonna definitely be a game changer
you